many for von Cook and Alberto bolado
have really cool jobs boniva uses
virtual reality to train people doing
work that involves life-or-death
decisions and Alberto is studying how
galaxies are born you know no big deal I
talked to them about their research and
the importance of diversity and science
so VR is by most people known primarily
in the gaming space but what a lot of
people don't know is that it's used a
lot now in research it's being used now
for training we use virtual reality in
situations where it might not be
feasible or it might not be advisable to
go into the actual scenario and interact
with individuals think about a pilot
interacting with a cockpit intubated you
don't really want to go in there and run
a study to assess their performance
while they're trying to operate a plane
planes are just one of the high stress
settings that mineka simulates in VR
she's also created simulations for
nuclear control rooms intense group
therapy sessions and even hospitals what
they have in some of these larger
hospitals is something called those
calamity rooms which is basically a
control room where you have a bunch of
operators called telemetry operators who
monitor several patients for example you
can have up to 64 patients in some of
these larger telemetry bed hospitals
monitored by just one operator and in
the case of a patient who's maybe being
monitored in a post operative setting
seconds matter instead of going into the
actual environment we can simulate the
distractions the alarm timing the
auditory and visual signals in a
repeatable controlled laboratory
simulation and then we can look at how a
operator might respond to those timing
accuracy and their work
Alberto uses really big radio telescopes
to answer some really big questions what
I try to do is I try to understand how
the universe came to do casita to the
end also my personal interest is in
understanding how galaxies evolved
through time you know galaxies are some
of the coolest objects that I can look
at like all kids interested in astronomy
it was interesting the in the majesty of
the universe and you know all those
wonderful pictures of you know galaxies
taken with large telescopes
Alberto's first experience using one of
these telescopes was unique after he
left his native Uruguay to come to the
United States to pursue his ph.d he got
an opportunity to work on a telescope in
a really far-flung place you had the
chance to actually go to contact again
the textbook was going to be there at
the South Pole what could be more
exciting than getting necessarily c-130
and flying you know to a model on the
coast and then taking another one to fly
to the center of the continent and
spending weeks at a time
a14 in you know the center of Antarctica
and he was you know it was a wonderful
cook into becoming more of an expert in
garlic seas and the interstellar medium
and how stars form and what is a
chemistry you know clouds and between
the stars I also spoke with dr. Shirley
Malcolm a longtime advocate for
diversity in science about the
importance of making science open to
everybody we have a lot of big
challenges we're looking at climate
change we're looking at speeding and
ever-growing population and food
security we are never really going to be
able to address those goals without
diverse populations really putting their
minds to it we need different
perspectives we need different
experiences we need different points of
view different lenses all coming to bear
on these really really serious big
challenges
the more perspectives that you have the
more diverse perspectives you have the
more innovative solutions you can come
up with and those even your points come
from the fact that they have different
technical backgrounds you know they come
from different cultures and they see the
problems in different ways so I think
that that is a value of the diversity in
these contexts I have said in many
occasions that there's talent going to
waste and that we need that talent we
need to bring their talents into science
and engineering and mathematics into
invention and innovation well I think
one of the hurdles facing people of
color and STEM fields is visibility so
if you don't see anyone that looks like
you pursuing something it's not seen as
it's not seen as a field that might be
attainable it's very difficult to become
something you've never seen I had to
become something I've never seen and it
makes it real hard if you know that you
are plowing new ground with more
individuals now going into stem or of
color
I think that's helping visibility of it
that's also helping some of the younger
children to see that that this might be
a pathway that is feasible for them to
pursue I could argue that we need to be
able to have more women of and already
the persons with disabilities or low
income or other people being able to
enter the sciences in engineering
because it's the right thing to do it is
inviting
the circumstances that have told people
back from being able to go into these
fields need to be removed the various
need to be removed but it isn't just the
right thing to do it's the smart thing
and smart in the sense of having that
talent available to you to address the
big issues health food energy climate
those things are going to be with us for
a while and we're going to have to deal
with them